aujourd'hui la météo est avec nous nous
avons mis nos chaussures de randonnée
nous sommes avec jean claude blain qui
fait partie du club de randonnée
d'éguzon qui va nous emmener faire une
petite balade est bien petite balade
donc au bord du lac sur le gr de pays
à tester racontez-moi ses sentiers ils
ont une histoire il date via plus de 30
ans et ça oui trente six ans puisque on
a commencé en 84 et on a lancé dans la
foulée donc la construction de deux
sentiers tout autour du lac
celui-ci la guérison mais aussi les deux
autres lacs
ce qui fait au total une centaine de
kilomètres en 6 7 mois
chaque week-end 30 35 bénévoles ont
coché dans la butte pour créer une
petite plate forme pour pouvoir passer à
pied soit là dans la queue dans les
côtes et donc on a débroussaillé créer
ce sentier manuellement
on peut le voir d'un peu plus près de la
coupe ah ah oui on le verra un peu plus
près donc quand on sera un peu plus loin
sur le sentier mais là on est en face
d'un petit passage secret alors allons-y
[Musique]
voilà un point de vue sur le lac la
plage de bonnut juste en face et la
plage d'éguzon là bas à droite c'est pas
très plat ainsi ça monte et ça descend à
ce sont les contreforts de la vallée de
la creuse
autrefois c'était des côtes qui était
pâturer par les moutons et les chèvres
donc c'est d'une végétation qui s'est
installée progressivement sur les
rochers elle est donc on trouve
essentiellement du biou et puis après
des châtaigniers puisque c'est que des
terrains
et puis après vous avez de l'épinoy
route avec les pin blanche un peu d'eux
un peu de chaînes qui gère aujourd'hui
tous ces sentiers et bien les sentiers
sont entretenus par les communes et bien
sûr des bénévoles toujours quand on
arrive on voit enfin le barrage
enfin le barrage donc c'est grâce à lui
qu'on a cette retenue d'eau ans la
championne à changer de moyen de
locomotion ray sur le bateau parce que
l'été on peut aussi utiliser des bateaux
oui pour des promenades mais également
lorsque l'on fait de la randonnée pour
avoir une boucle moins longue on peut
utiliser le bas qui a le bac qui
traverse d'une rive à l'autre donc qui
permet de faire une boucle d'une 14 14 à
15 km on reste sur le bateau on va
rentrer un autre point de départ et puis
on a goûté à la liqueur de châtaignes
incessants à la liqueur de chef et avec
modération
oui toujours